afghanistan a country which is sometimes
referred to as the graveyard of empires
the idea being that a great state comes
to conquer has a pretty difficult time
of it and the debacles there lead to the
eventual collapse of said state's empire
but this raises the question of just how
true this
is is afghanistan really the graveyard
of empires
so to begin the idea of there being a
state called afghanistan is a new one
the area and many parts of it had
changed hands many many times in the
past millennia
the persians the macedonians the admired
caliphate the mongols and their
successors were all able to hold and
control at least some of the territories
of what is now afghanistan and many did
so for a long time
and so this would suggest that
afghanistan isn't really the graveyard
of empires right
well kind of by the turn of the 19th
century an independent afghan state
existed and included much of what's now
modern-day pakistan
so what changed and how did afghanistan
get its reputation
well as of 1835 it looked like this
having lost some territory to the sikh
empire
also at this point the british were
strengthening their grip on india and
for them afghanistan appeared to be a
crisis waiting to happen since it could
be used by the ever-expanding russian
empire as a route to invade india
and as such the british opted to
befriend the emir of afghanistan
just kidding they invaded and tried to
replace him with his ousted predecessor
who they felt would be much nicer to
them
the british were confident that this
would be a somewhat quick and easy war
but fun fact
no at first things went well however
things turned sour pretty quickly
mostly because of the geography of
afghanistan and also the hostility of
the people there to outside rule and
eventually holding afghan territory
became too costly and so the british
opted to leave kabul which led to the
infamous 1842 retreat
as you know the british empire didn't
collapse in the wake of this loss and so
naturally afghanistan did not develop a
reputation of wrecking empires at this
point
this is doubly true when you consider
the fact that in 1878 britain invaded
again and this time they succeeded and
established a puppet leader there to
keep the russians away from india
and after this afghanistan was for the
most part a peaceful place and it wasn't
invaded again until the 1970s
this time by the soviet union in 1978
the afghan government was overthrown by
a communist coup with the backing of the
ussr
it began to centralize power and
implement broad sweeping reforms which
to put it mildly were not popular armed
insurrection began with the backing of
the western powers and the ussr
intervened in 1979 to prop up the
communist government there
at first things went well and the major
cities and the routes between them were
secured quickly
but a guerrilla war took hold and the
soviets lacked the ability to put an end
to the mujahideen's fight against them
and so
after 10 years of increasing costs in
terms of money and lives mikhail
gorbachev called for the withdrawal of
soviet troops
this was nothing short of an
international humiliation for the ussr
and as you'll know over two years later
the ussr had fully collapsed and it was
this that gave afghanistan its
reputation of being the graveyard of
empires
but is this a fair assessment well no
afghanistan being the place that empires
go to die is based almost exclusively
upon britain's troubles there the first
time it invaded
and also the ussr's collapsed shortly
after its withdrawal from there in 1989
to which the war in afghanistan only
played a very small part
to conclude afghanistan is simply not
the graveyard of empires
historically it's been fairly easy to
conquer and has been conquered many
times
although holding on to it is another
matter entirely i hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
a special thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker marvin
cassal rob waterhouse moe
james castaneda aaron the whites jordan
longley gustav swan jerry landon marcus
asner rasheed ali miss izek coppertone
spinning three plates maggie paxkowski
winston k wood matthew shipley spencer
lightfoot anthony beckett lexi schwinn
robert wedzill corso wolf sky chappelle
and charles the first